j'accueille yvan le bolloc'h
bruno solo réunit enfin réunis alors
vous n'êtes pas retrouver pour rien
puisque tous les soirs à 20h40 sur m6
quatre millions et demi de
téléspectateurs suivent
je sais tout c'est comme ça huit cent
mille de plus qu'à la rentrée c'est
énorme c'est vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup l'a1 d'un coup ça nous
arrive alors c'est une idée avoue un
ivan un soir sur le chemin entre la gare
et chez vous vous avez cette idée si
vous avez vu comment ben ça nous est
venue parce qu'on cherchait déjà depuis
longtemps un petit format moyen de faire
fortune non pas de faire fortune un
moyen de faire de faire de jouer la
comédie parce qu on était parti sur une
voie bon il fallait rentrer à la
télévision par
par n'importe quel moyen maintenant mais
je me lance dans le narratif c'est
normal dans une carrière ouais donc
apprendre à recentrer on était entré par
la porte des magazines et
divertissements puis après on voulait
faire de la comédie quoi donc on
cherchait un format économique et court
pour pouvoir rentrer à nouveau à la
télévision vous avez trouvé cette idée
qui est de raconter une entreprise à
travers ce que voit et entend une une
machine à café c'est un lieu clé de la
machine à café
bah oui c'est un endroit fédérateur
parce qu'il n'ya pas eu une entreprise
enfin dans les pme notamment et tout en
france on ne rentre dans le monde sur
aucun doute où il n'est pas une machine
à café c'est un endroit où effectivement
les gens se retrouvent pour parler d'une
autre manière
parler de leur vie en superficie certes
pas là de parler d'eux mêmes au sipi de
refaire le monde
donc c'était un vivier pour la comédie
formidable tout se passe là en fait tout
se fait et se défait devant la machine à
café
alors les personnages ou bruno et
responsables des achats
les syndicats délégué syndical crapules
un syndicaliste théoriquement
extrêmement engagé et courageux et dans
l'année dans les faits près veulent très
obséquieux avec les grands avalé un valu
une ordure et vous êtes cadre commercial
un peu frimeur c'est ça non j'ai pas les
moyens d'être sûrs déjà chez lui
disons que j'ai mis 15 ans d'arriver à
être cadre à la force du poignet je suis
plutôt un gros vendeur
voilà alors y'a plein de personnages
pied des guest stars il ya eu elie
semoun djamel josé guerra et puis alors
il ya plein de personnages et puis ya
aussi des guest stars il ya eu elie
semoun josé garcia qui d'autre est déjà
mais non je crois non jamais non
jamais il n'est jamais venu mais sinon
bon ben on va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble c'est comment on fait quand
même
ça c'est le dvd qu'il faut recommencer
ma chaise c'est pas de ma faute à moi à
l'heure
je veux bien maillé lozère bonjour
bonjour
annie touchante et hervé dumont
responsable des achats responsables et
attend des jeunes atout pour nos
rapports de sexe ou l'âge à la fois la
stagiaire de l'école de commerce de ce
parti là c'est un peu bizarre mais bon
je suis veuve et gameiro tu es un bon
logement met à la maison alors je me
suis dit allez je les reprendre des
études vous retrouver une nouvelle
jeunesse pour rennes vous allez bosser
avec jean claude convenant avec lui vous
allez faire le stage un type formidable
pédagogue au moins dix bien dix mois
hervé wes ton corps pour la nouvelle
stagiaire selimi qui ramassent
jean-claude se présenta n'y a ni
touchard de l'école de commerce donc
justement là c'est très bien
oui ça c'est vrai comme ça je
comprendrais mieux le travail que nous
voulons oui j'imagine que de votre côté
bon ben vous avez un petit peu a franchi
votre élève rassure le but de ce stage
toute façon d'ici dix minutes et sera là
je recommencerai le topo nécessaire si
là il fait très bien
et oui car ça se sentir plus en sécurité
pour la première rencontre jean-claude
quoi cette année caf a géré pendant un
mois et oui un jour dans mon service et
quinze jours dans ton service servait
comme ça annie aurait une vision plus
globale de l'entreprise
moi vous savez ma fuji d'infos mieux
c'est pour mon raf ont évidemment moi je
ne peux prendre personne dans mon
service et puis elle apprendra beaucoup
plus auprès de toi jean claude se sait
très bien on parle de son avenir la
niçoise charlieu en coûtait c'est
vraiment gentil parce que vous savez en
général et stagiaires sont tellement
maltraitée puisqu'elle parle de l'avenir
dany alors que moi je te parle de s'en
préserver
tu sais très bien que dans mon service
et stagiaires ne sont pas rémunérés et
moi je voudrais pas grand chose vous
savez je demande juste à nommay attend
sais pas ce que je vais lui donner
qu'elle pourra régler son loyer de
chambre d'étudiant de toute façon au 6e
sans ascenseur je suppose mais le fait
pas pour gagner de l'argent moi je le
fais pour mes peines oui oui mais leur
manque d'intérêt enfin annie quand même
s'il est dans ton service elle
bénéficiera d'une carte vermeil et un
repas chaud restée elle ne peut pas
bénéficier du resto u
ah bon et pourquoi ça parce qu'elles
gagnent une école privée pas mais moi
j'ai apporté mon manche et vous savez
c'est bon si elle est dans ton service
tu pourras au moins là pays hostiles au
monsieur le responsable des achats
parce que nous n'allons même si je le
paye un coût qui peut être obligé des
carreaux impôts la vie peau à à huy
ça lui ferait n'investissent call yes
échec et mat moi je voulais suisse non
attendez une seconde
en tout cas je te préviens tu as
peut-être gagner mais moi je fais pas le
corbillard tous les soirs et je
raccompagne phare dans son groupe
georges c'est d'accord t'es d'accord
si annie je veux plus faire ce stage
quoi abbaoui bon alors si vous n'êtes
pas motivé non pour rien enfin bon eh
oui bloquer dans le caméra café
c'est bien
c'est bien les prix ouais c'est bien
l'écrire on a une trentaine d'auteurs
qui travaillent avec nous il ya un
auteur potentiel ce travail que nous il
ya un noyau dur beaucoup de filles
beaucoup de filles notamment les
comédiennes art mais il joue mais eva
qui écrit beaucoup de sketches et et
costumière au départ oui tout à fait lui
pas comment tu sais ça merde non anciens
quand tu ces singes surtout à bank à
sédhiou ça me suffit comme explication
alors le tournage donc c'est une semaine
sur deux l'autre semaine c'est
l'écriture des scénarii et bruno vous
avez été obligé
bruno je voulais quitter la belgique et
de revenir habiter en france ça ça n'a
pas déchiré le coeur a dit quoi frédéric
si frédéric va
l'été on se voyait plus quoi en fait on
était quand séparés parce que moi je
passais beaucoup de temps ici avec le
mois suivant alors il commence à avoir
des doutes ça devenait ingérable sadisme
est donc maintenant j'ai ramené ma femme
à côté mais ça risque pas de [ __ ]
votre couple en l'air sa ferme le couple
aime et qui lancent ces faits soient
plus souvent pour les papiers du divorce
bien le dire et lui a lu et entendu
c'est elle qui préférait rentrer aussi
parce qu'elle travaille beaucoup plus en
france qu'elle ne travaillait en
belgique mandat corps au sens tout le
monde est content tout le monde est
content sauf les belges qui marquerait
donc vous êtes extrêmement sollicité
tous les deux par les filles on peut le
dire devant m6 tous les jours les essais
du mal à me dire ça on vient de parler
nos femmes si derrière dix ans vous ne
changerait dans la baie vous avez un
esprit extrêmement critique
fais attention ça va fuser dès que vous
voyez une gonzesse
vous savez tout de suite tout de suite
trouvé les tue l'amour c'est pourquoi je
vous dis ça n'est pas ce que vous allez
faire une interview tue l'amour
et ça tient debout chacun votre tour ça
commence par vous alors [ __ ]
la tension est chaud le détail du
l'amour chez une fille c'est les cheveux
gras les mains moites les poils sous les
bras ou le duvet sous le nez elle se bat
avec un mec des membres du labour
je sais pas moi à talon cassé ça ça fait
beaucoup
en fin de soirée sur un parking de bois
de melun surtout quand la femme en
question après tu te demandes de la
ramener mais à athis-mons vraie percée
des bordes fait airbus avec votre héros
qui en se disant que tu aurais pas
rasoir justement justement le super tue
l'amour
si les mauvaises odeurs la mauvaise
haleine ou mauvais goût enfin moi et moi
pour moi ces tutus vas-y le mauvais goût
bah évidemment le mauvais goût c'est le
mauvais goût qui serait d'avoir mauvaise
haleine
un cannibale vous avoir répondu à une
chose est sûre le mauvais goût il vous
auriez way le tue l'amour à la plage
c'est une fille qui garde le haut une
fille qui se fout à poil direct ou une
fille mal chichi garde le haut c'est
vrai c'est quand même assez bizarre
vient il vient pas en même temps grands
noms une fille si elle aime pas c'est
sain mais suffisamment sato fond la
montre et c'est vous
si vous pensez que le portel garde le
haut elle a enlevé le bas quand même ah
bah oui j'ai vu un gars de hockey ce que
vous il ya des refus
et vous quelles consignes que manny
semble alors le tue l'amour en boîte une
fille qui danse désynchronisée une fille
qui dégoulinent de sueur pour une fille
bourrée s'il bourré ça peut être un gain
de l'amour ça doit être là c'est
l'occasion de réussir tout élu après les
satisfactions d'amour n'est peut-être
pas le montant des biens le baiser qui
tue l'amour c'est une fille qui embrasse
tout le monde à pleine bouche une fille
qui envoie son chien sur le museau ou
une fille qui fait cas de bise parce que
chez nous c'est 4 c'est quoi la la
première celle qui embrasse tout jeune
bojan fait clair ça se faire pas laisser
remet en confiance on dit ou la salle
être une fille légère et c'est un
euphémisme
alors le tue l'amour avant de conclure
ouais c'est pega fais gaffe je prends
pas la pilule je te préviens je suis
frigide
tu sais j'ai mais qu'est ce que c'est le
deuxième déjà su friggit te préviens je
suis plus frais mais là on voyait un
challenge et étudierait attentivement
conclure c'est un gros match un gros qui
frappe derrière la porte en disant je
suis bûcheron ça fait une semaine
et si son mari en bleu alors le tue
l'amour au lit c'est la fille qui bouge
pas la fille qui hurlent ou la fille qui
pleure
fille qui pleure ça veut dire que tu as
pas que tu as loupé le challenge suisse
rigide d'un gars et si elle pleure de
rire c'est plié encore bon maintenant on
se réveille tue l'amour au réveil de la
fille qui fait un gargarisme en se
lavant les dents contre la fille qui met
un déodorant son bond de douche qui ne
l'a fait ou la féministe raitt et où la
fille qui laisse la porte des toilettes
ouvertes quand elle y va alors ça c'est
battre un jeu ça va être un truc et
antique
ouais pas le matin quoique vraiment
attaché au rugby après je sais pas moi
[ __ ] tu m'aides pas tous aussi à qui
franck imedi déodorant sans prendre de
douche ou et pourquoi pas ce que dit ce
que je dis merde et aux essais com - et
de son pack all de limites
voilà caméra café yvan le bolloc'h et
bruno
et maintenant je suis
boissier l'a9 drôle
bon sous le poids de votre gueule quand
vint alors il est ici parce que vous
êtes à la fiche du raid
un film de djamel bensalah avec roschdy
zem lorànt deutsch julien courbet mais
avec un y évidemment atmen kelif josiane
balasko et gérard jugnot
le réalisateur bas le coscénariste et le
co dialoguiste avec gilles laurent c'est
donc djamel bensalah qui a fait un
carton en 99 avec le ciel les oiseaux et
ta mère voilà with the pitch ouais c'est
mieux c'est vrai vous ferait plaisir à
faire que faut vous alors quel métier
dans le film vous appelez les honneurs
de ségonzac vous êtes une riche
héritière qui passe son temps à faire
des raids et qu'il ya beaucoup de
malchance
enfin c'est ce qu'on croit au début du
film et sa étonnerait personne si elle
mourrait pendant le raid qu'elle prépare
enfin c'est ce que pense l'avocat de la
famille qui est un avocat véreux qui est
langage des tueurs pour éliminer et
leonardo ségonzac c'est à dire vous
pendant le raid
mais il ya un quiproquo énorme les
quatre vrais tueurs sont une bande de
bras cassés et qu'elle passe son temps à
sauver
ils ont été sélectionnés parmi les
meilleurs
ils sont forts ouais mais cassant mais
non
oui nord ça vous plairait prendre l'air
aux kabyles sont hyper motivés rien à
faire au canada
ils n'ont peur de rien comment ils
claquent l'hôtel sa mère réservations
chambre 68 au monde latin kings famille
funky vite family avec un riff en
parlent ils sont prêts pour leur raid
largué en pleine nature nos aventuriers
de pur
désormais compter que sur cette
magnifique carte 1
quoi moi je sais pas lire une carte
banon vous ne seriez pas ailleurs une
carte non moi qu'on appelle la boussole
du 9-3 je sais pas lire une carte
je suis à côté de toi arrivé j'ai mal au
ventre ali ben ben hassen qantas
baratin on va quand on n'est pas en
vacances on sait qu'on n'est pas en
vacances elle est peut-être trop bonne
mais aujourd'hui et vous 4 millions de
dollars pour la craie les ranchs et nos
mères
ces mobiles à la grèce
là je reconnais vraiment dans la merde
7 mars de fne lorraine
jalel ben salah avec hélène de
fougerolles l'humanité ce soir
c'est un petit film indépendant qu'on a
fait on traduit en deux trois semaines
et alors donc tournage au venezuela en
louisiane bien sûr en france est
dangereuse tournage avait failli vous
noyez vous sous une bâche ouais mais
comment savez-vous 700 joueurs si ce
soir
c'est quand même je dirais plus
incroyable alors raconté cette noyade
s'est il y avait une scène on devait
passer sous un énorme boudin on voyait
pas ce qu'il y avait derrière on nous a
dit vous apparaissez de l'autre côté il
ya la caméra sauf que moi j'ai plongé et
de ce côté c'était toujours noir en
justice au venezuela je sais pas ce
qu'ils avaient dans l'eau et donc je
vous ouvrez les yeux et c'est passé et
puis en fait j'ai un moment je suis
remonté j'ai pris une bonne bâches en
plastique collée son numéro et et moi
j'ai paniqué donc j'étais tout mon père
j'ai perdu le sens de l'orientation les
garçons ont fait demi tour et se
retourner votre côté et moi j'ai eu peur
et donc j'ai gratté et donc je suis et
j'ai réussi à trouver un trou j'ai sorti
ma tête
alors le plus insupportable son c'était
sans doute les quatre mecs qui vous dit
deux cents à elle est bonne puisque
bonne non ouais il n'ya pas les bonnes
et il disait je suis senti très bien les
escalopes jus je vais très bien la
lunette arrière mais revient j'aimerais
bien d'une culture et d'un bon ok c'est
pas de copine pas de copies du bac avec
des garçons et puis robin est que t'es
pas là ouais c'est chiant c'était dur
remis net ces machins
bénard
mais bon
maintenant je suis on va faire un nom et
pas de quoi avoir peur
docteur jekyll et mister hyde
alors on commence par le docteur jekyll
ou vous êtes aristo mais vous n'avez pas
gardé leur iguane si vous appelez votre
vrai nom c'est hélène ghiwane de
fougerolles voilà non plus bon vous avez
pas n'ai pas été élevé trop cateau et
pour une pour une noble en fait vous
êtes assez cool non je m'attends à le
lâcher
ouais ouais ouais ouais non je suis pas
né avec une cuillère en argent dans la
bouche je suis plutôt voilà quoi non
mais j'ai une petite éducation à mon
avis qui fait que je peux être poli en
même temps avec les trois mois et demi
que j'ai passé avec les garçons je fais
des mauvais choix
voilà j'ai pas trop la ramener parce que
j'ai peur de ce qui arrive après ben ali
pourtant j'ai quand même ma mère look
ont une allure pas très populaire c'est
par un handicap pour votre carrière
honnêtement moi je m'en rends pas compte
d'eux si on voit tout de suite élaine
deveault la particule si elle vient tout
de suite j'ai pas l'impression d'avoir
eu des rôles forcément grâce ou à cause
de ça de ségonzac je pense que ça a bien
aidés mais ça m'a bien arrangé
et sinon je pense que je suis j'ai la
race et accessible
les gens me disent pas j'ai l'air trop
bourgeoise je ne comptons bureau là vous
avez bien sorti ouais ouais non j'ai
adoré tourner ce truc là surtout de
faire un genre de james bond indiana
jones tomb raider en france ouais ouais
ouais super contente
c'est pas gênant d'être découvertes
travers un film aussi baroque que le
raid vous auriez pas préféré devenir
star avec tavernier par exemple
mais qu'est ce qui vous dit que j'allais
devenir stable certes on joue encore
galérer vivant
donc non on verra j'ai l'impression que
tout le monde petit chemin tranquille ou
quoi qu'est si on affiche 69 c'est vous
qui me poser des questions
j'ai calqué salalah alors avant quel est
le moment où vous à vignes de plus le
plus honte non mais vit le jour je me
suis fait choper pour avoir photocopié
six pages dans un bouquin j'ai honte de
moi je voulais écrire 292 et est clair
ça vous va maintenant vous êtes
populaire vous pensez ça y est vous êtes
passés de l'autre côté parce que vous
avez longtemps attendu de faire un gros
film comme ça ouais ouais bah en même
temps je recherche pas forcément à être
populaire
j'aimerais être pote tu veux pas faire
un gros truc qui cartonne pourraient
avoir accès à des films mais déroule qui
m'intéresserait peut-être plus en même
temps en ce moment ça va mieux je suis
sur des trucs que j'ai le choix puisque
avant j'ai envie de dire
alors tout le monde commence à connaître
hélène de fougerolles pourtant souvent
on vous appelle encore anne-marie le
[ __ ] c'est vrai oui bain-marie c'était
dans le collège de kerman qui n'est ce
pas non ça faisait remarquer anne marie
pendant cinq ans et la cct filet parce
qu'on vous parle encore de mal et aux
airs c'est méchant